so the halo 5 Guardians beta starts in a
little under two months Robin I got to
play it in that right rub that is
correct yeah so we played about two
hours of a competitive multiplayer
that's gonna be the focus of the beta
this kind of like arena eSports style
they like to drop those words in during
the demo team slayer and then a new mode
breakout but before we get into that and
the three maps that we played on we
should really talk about the the most
prevalent thing the most like
fundamental change to halo 5 Guardians
well to the halo multiplayer experience
in guardians and that's mobility yes and
when they showcase this it was
impossible to not think about call of
duty and the dashing and all these
elements of like the exosuit yeah so you
can do a dash with the press of a button
to the side to the back to the front
it's not really a double jump per se but
in the place of double jump they have
clamber like you can jump and like climb
up onto a Ledge as opposed to all your
like previously impotent halo stuff
where you like oh right you try to do
that jump where you like jump duck and
then get up and then stand up right you
can now like climb your way up there
right the mobility is kind of like a
horizon down to other thing like yeah
you can't necessarily get as high as
you'd like compared to call of duty
everything is kind of like directionally
down so you have to have a kind of
similar thing which is like the they
call it the ground pound yeah which is
you know similar call duty it's a you
know you're in midair and you can pound
out on someone and eliminate
yeah but it's not like but stomps that
you've seen in other games which are
pretty instant it's kalite like though
in you know Borderlands the pre-sequel
in any game where you sort of our
stomping downwards I feel like once
you're up above the person boom you're
stomping down in guardians you have to
target you have to like hold it down and
charge it up so you're hovering in air
this reticle appears on the ground and
once it's good you kind of like a
challenge like rock it down yeah and it
was cool to kind of I mean you know
first attempt just completely yeah and
you ever pull it off successfully
eventually I did and it's pretty
rewarding because it's you know it's not
it's not easy you are floating target
you're a literally hovering therefore
I'd say it solid like 23 seconds took a
little bit of splash damage like you
might duck their shields if you miss
right ah but like you're saying people
are always moving cuz you can sprint
like unlimitedly yeah anyone can sprint
at any time all the time the the
drawback there is that while you're
sprinting your shields don't regenerate
so there's kind of like when you're in a
firefight all you sprint away it's fine
but if you're sprinting away you're not
getting those shields back so it sort of
introduces this balance which i think is
kind of neat yeah I felt myself that was
one of the sort of things that you know
they introduced this whole suite of
movement abilities for us and we've had
like a short amount of time to play with
it that was one of the things that
immediately hit was like I want aspirin
I want to get away but now I feel like
take a second recharge my shields like
that was like immediately communicable
to me within the language of sort of
halo multiplayer in my experience but
with sprinting you also have to charge
where if you sprint you'll you know like
once you get to full speed which takes
like four or five steps or so sure you
get this reticle that comes up and you
basically if you mail a while doing that
you go mmm and if you nail someone from
the side of the front their shields are
gone but if you nail from behind dead so
we play team deathmatch yeah I played on
a couple different maps one of them was
called truth was basically midship a
spiritual successor to midship had the
prophet of truth like talking in his
little Holograms a few places around the
map so that was a big circular one we
play it on another one called empire
with new which is new and it's broken up
it's a small it's a small map but it's a
lot more broken up with different
platforms and there was
some intense sniper battles yeah sniper
and heavy ammo of heavy weapons by the
way are now like announced everyone
knows now that if you count down every
10 seconds so it neither coming in 20
minutes 26 seconds 10 seconds damn
everyone yeah everyone is rushing this
point it's and it's also indicated where
the hell it is the other mode we played
in addition to team slayer was breakout
this is a new one for halo but not new
for competitive shooters it's basically
everyone gets one life in a given round
and once you're down you don't respawn
and whoever has the last man standing
that team wins the round first five
round wins wins and we played it on this
weird for jable map that was all like
Tron ified it was like a mix between
Iran it like a paintball a professional
paintball field yeah it was fun it was
really competitive there's a chance it
was intense and of course you know this
is something where you really want to be
talking to other people like hands down
you wanted like take over this type of
feeling mode you need communicating with
everyone else and especially because
once you die you get a third person view
of any of your teammates so you can be
the scout like you can see the
peripheral vision that they can't
because they're in first person and you
can chat with them about it so yeah
communication while maybe we didn't do
such a super job of it during the actual
event it shouldn't be that important for
breakout so yeah halo 5 Guardians beta
coming soon looks kind of interesting it
looks interesting definitely sort of in
that modern trend of mobility changes
that we've seen you know with titanfall
and call of duty this year notably ah
kind of excited for it kind of site for
it you know first reaction was you know
oh god they they fell for it as well but
you know when it came down to it where
they went forward as well exactly yeah
but when it comes down to it it was fun
and I could see a game successful
you
you